All right, with that we move on to item D, public hearing to consider zoning code amendment
number 2107, ZCA 2107, eliminating expansion or establishment of truck intensive uses in
various commercial industrial and manufacturing zones, initiation of a general plan amendment
and zoning amendment to change the land use in various industrial and manufacturing zones
in the city and extending the temporary moratorium on expansion or establishment of truck
intensive uses within five industrial and manufacturing areas for an additional one-year period.
Mr. Patches, may we have a staff report on this item?
Thank you, members of the City Council, Jim Patches, Principal Planner, and this plan
are proud to be working on this project for about a year now, so I think we started the
moratorium in January of last year or this year.
Anyway, so just to give you some quick background, this all started with a lot of concerns
about truck intensive uses in the high level of traffic, zoning code, zoning code in general
plan on not being sufficient to address those impacts and also just a need to clarify our
code and for the code to be something that really reflects community values.
So we kind of started this process by defining what truck intensive uses are to use as kind
of a guiding principle for the project and the basic definition is really consistent
with the concerns that we were hearing the community express and the City Council express,
which is that these types of uses created significant volumes of traffic, they had adverse
impacts to residential neighborhoods such as blight, impacts and infrastructures, deuteriation,
noise and air pollution, traffic congestion, and just impacts on pedestrian safety and
conflicts between the truck use and pedestrians navigating their neighborhoods.
Also the use is have an impact of reducing the livability of our community, really without
generating much revenue for the City and not really producing significant jobs for
our residents.
So this is just a quick outline of how we got here, again as I mentioned we started
in January 21st, 2021 where we first initiated the amendment to the general plan on zoning
code and also adopted a moratorium and then in February of that this year we extended the
moratorium to January 22nd, 2022 and then in September of this year we had our first
stakeholder meeting with the different user groups of truck intensive use organizations
and also property owners and then we had a follow-up meeting with the Planning Commission
and City Council to get input on the initial direction that we were proposing to take
and got feedback on that and with that feedback we came back and wrote the draft ordinance
and then went to the Planning Commission about a month ago on October 27th and the Planning
Commission reviewed the documents in a recommended approval 5 to 0.
So the scope of the discussion tonight is really three components.
The first we'll I'll go over a summary of the draft truck intensive use ordinance.
Then I'll talk about some recommendations to initiate certain land use of recommendations
in our industrial zones in the city and then we'll have a discussion on the potential one
year extension of the truck intensive use moratorium to just specifically for areas in
the city where the image zoning is being recommended to change land use to another zone.
So the first component is the ordinance itself and I think as I mentioned I think this is
my fourth presentation on this topic so forgive me for the repetitiveness in some cases.
But as I mentioned throughout this process distribution warehouse already had a good solution
with the overlay zones and requiring general plan amendments and the City Council has the
discretion to allow it or not allow it whether it makes sense in the particular location
and prohibited in areas where it doesn't make sense.
So we didn't touch that particular aspect of the code.
What we did do is we established where truck intensive uses can go and that zone is the
manufacturing heavy zone and the direction in the code is just to allow truck intensive
uses there where the conditional use permit.
Also we added certain provisional requirements to require truck intensive uses to be better
neighbors where they are allowed.
And then in kind of the connection with that or together with that we're also removing truck
intensive uses from the MSC, the MM and the IP industrial zones and that will address a
lot of the scattered small parcel development industrial developments throughout the city
which has been somewhat problematic for code enforcement at times.
So this is just a map that shows and purple all the existing manufacturing high zones in
the city where truck intensive uses can be allowed.
And then in addition to directing those truck intensive uses in those locations shown
on the previous map, we also are prohibiting some specific uses.
The first is vehicle storage.
It's going to be limited at least to vehicle storage only when it's ancillary to a primary
use or if it's entirely within an enclosed building.
And then we're just also prohibiting outside storage in general for just a blanket use.
So again, outside storage can be done with contract for storage or in the MH zone but
it couldn't be done ancillary or all by itself.
And then finally, we're prohibiting truck stops and travel centers throughout the city
and that goes beyond just the industrial zones but also includes the commercial zones where
gas stations are allowed or service stations.
And then as I was developing this ordinance, we also realized that there needs to be some
clarifying language added to the MH zone because as I stated in the staff report, our goal
was to eliminate vehicle storage throughout the city and we need to add in two particular
uses under the conditional uses permitted, the sentence or added to the end of the land
use a sentence that says entirely within an enclosed building with no outdoor storage
allowed.
So that's just clear that applies to the MH zone and all the other industrial zones.
So we'd like to recommend that language be added to the ordinance tonight.
And then it's also important to clarify that certainly because of the ordinance, assuming
that it is adopted, the proposed ordinance would create some non-conforming uses but
within the existing code under the non-conforming use section, any legally established use that
becomes non-conforming because of a zone amendment may remain in place for 40 years from the
effective date of the amendment.
So these non-conforming uses that are legal at the time of the adoption of the ordinance
or the effective date of the ordinance don't have to pack up and leave, they have a 40-year
amortization period to transition.
Those uses would also be allowed to do up to a 25% expansion in the use over that time.
So when we kind of casted this net for truck-intensive uses, there was a number of proposals in
the pike that were held up because of the moratorium which really were defined as truck
uses but they weren't truck-intensive.
So as we brought up in the previous meetings, we looked for ways to maybe allow those uses
as long as they weren't actually truck-intensive.
So what we did was we looked at some other uses that everybody is familiar with.
We did an evaluation of a study of supermarkets and we found that supermarkets will generally
it was thought that supermarkets were a real impactful use to residential and they're
often located in residential areas or near them.
So that was why we kind of chose that particular use.
And we looked at an extensive study that determined that an average supermarket generates 18 truck
trips a day that's there and back.
So we looked at that as one form of evaluation.
We also looked at a couple of the uses, some of the uses that were in process.
One was an example of a kind of a mom-and-pop contractor storage, a company, been in a riverside
area for 40 years and they were proposing a building on a one-acre site, 10,000 square
feet.
It only generates four truck trips a day.
So we felt that was a pretty safe parameter for consideration in terms of how do we define
these kind of uses.
We also looked at another use, the example here is a cold storage proposal that is less
than I think it's 20,000 square feet and it generates 12 truck trips a day.
So after our evaluation, we came up with some parameters for these kind of truck uses that
aren't truck-intensive.
And what we set them at is cold storage yards, equipment sales, storage, salvage yards, warehouses
without distribution, those kinds of uses could be allowed if the site was under one acre,
less than 30,000 square feet of building area and more than 500 feet away from a residential
or a sensitive use.
And that the process involved in reviewing these would require a CUP and would also include
new rule-based standards which I'll talk about in a second.
And it also would include a standard condition of approval that requires continued demonstration
of operational compliance with the approvals of the project.
And if those weren't adhered to, then there would be the ability to modify or revoke
the use permit.
So the updated standards would apply to these types of uses.
In addition, we are going to be applying them to the MH zone for the truck-intensive uses
as best management practices and reducing impacts to neighboring uses.
So those include complete screening of some of the areas that are less slightly such as
loading zones, service areas, trash enclosures, truck and trailer parking.
And screening would include the buildings themselves, landscaping, berms, decorative walls and those
sorts of things.
We would also require that all outside storage be completely screened from public view and
that the outside storage be prohibited in the setback areas and that any perimeter walls
or screen walls be located along or include landscaping in front of it between the street
and the walls themselves to lessen their impacts.
And then all screen walls be a minimum of eight feet in height to ensure that they provide
proper screening.
Oops, I'm too many, sorry.
I'm going in also, next slide, that all screen walls have an anti graffiti and vehicle parking
lots and driveways and storage areas be paved and that the properties be required to be
in good maintenance and repair at all times.
And then finally, based on our workshop with the Planning Commission and City Council, we
added two new provisions to this section, which includes that heavy duty trucks and
similar heavy equipment not be allowed to idle more than five minutes.
That's pretty much a standard sequoque condition that we put on some of the truck distribution
uses that have been approved in the last several years.
And also included is a requirement that landscaping be designed to reduce gluten dispersal.
So as part of this, we included definitions to the ordinance to address some of the new
sections.
But first is the truck stop travel centers since we're prohibiting them.
We wanted to make it clear in the code what they are.
We also added research and development because that was absent from some of the other industrial
zones and it was used at the general plan, wanted to encourage.
We also updated the warehouse distribution definition to just clarify that these kinds
of uses generate truck traffic and have more impacts than some of the other industrial uses.
In drain freighting and truck operations definition, we just specified or included the dispatching
of fleet and truck pickup and delivery goods and basically dispatch type centers be included
in that kind of a use.
And then finally, a definition for heavy duty truck vehicles, which goes with the idling requirement
would be any vehicle over 26,000 pounds and this is just an example of those types of trucks
basically class seven and class eight trucks, refuge, trash trucks, furniture trucks, buses,
cement trucks, dump trucks and truck tractors, those kinds of trucks.
So that concludes the summary of the proposed ordinance and then the next thing that I'd
like to talk about is the proposed study areas or land use changes.
And we looked at five study areas plus Sierra Avenue north boundary, which I'll talk about
a little bit more in a second.
And then the North Penn-Pyrite area, which has a master plan being developed on it, that
was basically deferred for now to allow us more time to look at the different issues
such as the mining facility and the string fellow acid pits and what limitations they
may hold to potential land uses in that area.
So here's just a map of the different areas that I'll discuss.
The first one I'd like to go over is the Belltown Algomansa study area and this, you
don't have to give you some background, we went through each of these study areas and did
a land use inventory to get a good understanding of the different land uses that are currently
there and what's vacant and also what's non-conforming and where the residential is.
And we looked at the existing zoning and the existing general plan land uses for each study
area.
So for this particular area for Belltown Algomansa, we're making several recommendations.
One of the distinctions that we noticed is that 28th Street, everything south of 28th
Street is primarily residential commercial with a little bit of business park mixed in.
So we want to make sure that there's no more encroachment of any kind of industrial uses
south of that line.
And we also noted that north of 28th allows primarily business park and industrial uses.
And we really see the opportunity to create a rubido business park corridor along rubido
boulevard.
So that's basically the emphasis of that and that would go along with proposed rubido
specific plan to do improvements in the area.
And specifically we would look at enhancing the types of uses along the rubido boulevard
area particularly for more business park type uses and job generating type of uses and
also to do improvements to the landscaping and the parkway and the meetings there.
And provide a better entry point from the 60 freeway to the rubido algomansa area.
The next area I'd like to talk about is Belgrade Bambiran.
So currently the use has a lot of the uses out there have a lot of the truck storage
yards uses that have been somewhat problematic in the community.
The area is primarily zoned, MSC.
And if you look at the general plan, there's the goal to transition this area to mostly business
park.
The area in Pink is business park and the area in kind of the light purple is light industrial.
So the recommendations here is just to change the MSC to business park to be consistent
with the general plan.
And also a big part of this is doing an update and modernization to our business park zoning
standards.
Right now they're not really entirely consistent with our goals in the general plan.
Whoops, things are sensitive.
So for the business park standards what we're looking at is first of all we're going to require
site development permits for all land uses within the business park zone.
Currently some of the uses don't require any discretionary review.
So we want to just make it consistent with other industrial zones in the city.
We also are going to be updating the list of land uses, removing those that are consistent
with what the general plan envisions for the business park areas.
And also requiring conditional use permits for the more intensive uses.
Also we're looking at enhancing the architectural design requirements for the business park areas.
And also I would like to consider maybe creating some new design guidelines for the business parks.
And included in your packet we did take a quick stab at amending that particular section to give you guys an idea or
a flavor of how that might look and trying to improve and more modernize the land uses within that area.
So the next area is the airport area.
This one's a little less complicated than some of the others.
Basically going to remove the existing MH zone.
So the whole airport area is all zoned MSC,
at least in the interim to do kind of a first step.
And then we're also recommending that we develop an airport specific plan or at least an airport zoning district.
And that we would move forward with that as kind of a later version of kind of these implementation of these land use recommendations
if initiated by the city council.
And then the next area is the Pedley-Lemonite study area.
Again this one has some of the truck storage yard issues,
particularly up on the upper half of Amburen.
And if you look at that particular area, it's zoned MSC and the general plan again of the pink area is business park.
And then our recommendations here are to address that inconsistency and again change the MSC zones to business park.
And then also there's some specific changes adjacent to Clay Street, as you know recently Appaloosa Springs was approved as a residential development.
So clearly that zoning has been established in that particular area.
But then across the street right now that is proposed to be CN, and business park on the top.
And there's a concern with that business park at the top because we have two existing uses.
One is basically a senior congregate care facility which isn't allowed in business park currently.
And then also a medical facility at the top.
So we just want to make the zoning there consistent with the existing land uses.
We think they're good land uses and we'd like to make them conforming.
And then finally the last area I'd like to touch on is the Sierra Avenue in the northern city border.
And this particular area is all zoned MH and my understanding in the history of this is that the previous mining facility that the Oak quarry golf courses currently occupying had used that as kind of a staging area.
And it was an envisioned by the county that that would be expanded over to this area.
Of course that never happened.
And so we're just recommending that this area be changed again consistent with the general plan land uses.
Which currently the land use there is OS rural and also LDR.
And so we're going to recommend those changes be made just to note that the area along Sierra Avenue currently has a housing track proposal.
So we'll probably let that process go through the system and whatever gets approved or not approved.
We'll follow suit with the zoning on that one.
So the last part I'd like to talk about is the extension of the moratorium.
And just as I mentioned earlier the moratorium would if nothing were to happen would expire January 22 2022.
But there are four areas in the city where there's manufacturing high zones that are proposed to be changed to a new zone where trucking heads of east wouldn't be allowed.
So we're recommending to those particular areas that the overlay be the moratorium be extended to those particular four areas to give us time to process a land use amendments.
I'd like to mention that these amendments once they're initiated by the planning commission will come in a series of processes.
And we'll start with what we call the low hanging fruit.
And to tell you the truth these areas here will just be changed to be consistent with the general plan.
Which ought to be done anyway.
It's just a course of action that the city would take.
So that would be in our first phase and we would start that soon after the new year.
And then this map just shows the four different areas.
The one was the Sierra area that it is discussed and one in Augelmanza.
One is the airport so that that one can happen fairly quickly.
And the last one is kind of in the southern part of the city.
A big chunk of that is open space and right next to the Santa Ana River.
So it can't be developed anyhow.
And the only other area in that particular location is currently commercial uses.
I think one's in and out broker and the other one's sizzler.
So those probably wouldn't be developed as any from any market.
We will move forward with those land use changes right away.
So what we're recommending is first to conduct a first reading of and introduce the ordinance.
To eliminate the expansion or establishment of truck intensive uses and various commercial and industrial manufacturing zones.
With the clarification I made earlier in my presentation.
Or vehicle storage, trailer and boat storage in the image zone prohibiting those uses other than inside a building.
And then initiate the general plan amendments that I summarized.
And then also initiate a zoning to code amendment to the business park zone to update that.
And finally to adopt by a four or fifths boat.
The extension of an urgency ordinance over those four areas to January 22nd, 2023.
And I really feel confident we won't need that much time in order to fix the land uses and then lift the moratorium.
So that concludes my presentation. Happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, Mr. Patches. Any questions for staff at this time?
Nope. All right. With that, I will open the public hearing.
Mr. Blankenship, am I understanding that you're yielding your time?
I'll be brief.
Good evening, Honorable Mayor and members of the City Council.
My name is Bill Blankenship. I'm the Government Affairs Director for Neop
in the Empire Chapter. Simply tonight, we're specifically concerned with the overall concept
that there is a state need for arbitrary setbacks, which is stated in the pending ordinance and was
recommended at the October 27th, 2021 meeting of the City's Planning Commission to address the need
for setbacks to sensory receptors based on air quality, NEOP, IE has submitted to the City Council
a study that was completed in April of 2021 and was completed by Ramble,
titled Evaluating Sitting Distances for New Sensory Receptors and New Wearhouses.
NEOP IE Chapter is in support of the public hearing item 13D, items one through three.
We continue to have concerns with the need for a moratorium, even if it impacts 13 parcels,
as we believe that those projects would have to change their zoning to move forward.
And that certainly gives a city tremendous ability to regulate if those projects go forward.
At this time, I would like to introduce Lakshmi Jaran, who's a senior managing consultant at
Ramble who will briefly share with you the Council some highlights from the study.
I'd like to ask her to come up and take my remaining time.
I would like to point out to you that we worked closely with your staff and
would like to thank you for that opportunity to do that and would like to thank staff
for their professionalism and that great working relationship.
Thank you for providing me with the opportunity to comment.
As Bill mentioned, I work with Ramble.
Ramble is a global engineering architecture and consultancy company with 16,000 experts
across 35 countries. I'm part of the air quality group in Southern California.
A big part of my job is to use my scientific expertise and technical skills
to develop sustainable solutions that are protective of human health and the environment.
Today I'll be talking about our evaluation of the siting distances for sensitive receptors
near warehouses based on the current state of science.
In 2005, the California Air Resources Board published a land use guidance that recommends
a minimum separation distance of 1,000 feet between new sensitive land uses and warehouses
that accommodate more than 100 trucks per day or 300 hours per week of transportation
refrigeration units also known as TRUs. A lot has changed since then.
Diesel particulate matter emissions from both trucks as well as TRUs have reduced significantly
as seen on the two graphs on this slide. Further, the Office of Environmental Health
Hazard Assessment updated their guidance for estimating health risk in 2015
by incorporating aid sensitive factors for children that increased the risk associated with diesel
PM by a factor of 2.5. In order to evaluate how these changes affect carbs recommended
siting distance of 1,000 feet, Ramble conducted a health risk assessment of two warehouse scenarios
in calendar years 2000 and 2023. These include a trucks with TRU scenario
which represents a warehouse that can accommodate 40 trucks per day and 300 hours of TRU operation
per week and a truck only scenario that represents a warehouse that accommodates 100 trucks per day.
Emission estimates for onsite activity for these two scenarios in 2000 and 2023 are shown in this
graph. There are significant decreases in emissions from 2000 to 2023. This is a result of the
implementation of several federal and state regulations on trucks and TRUs including carbs
truck and bus regulation that requires the statewide truck fleet to convert to 2010 on
newer model vehicles by January 1st, 2023. The results of the health risk modeling are shown
in this slide. The graph on the slide compares Ramble's results with carbs analysis that
was used to set the 1,000 feet siting distance. The height of the bars on this chart represent
distances from the center of the modeled warehouse where the estimated residential cancer risk is
greater than 100 in a million. The purple bar here shows carbs results for TRU operation that was
used to set the recommended distance of 1,000 feet which is also represented here on this graph
by the solid blue line at the top. The first light yellow bar beside the purple bar is Ramble's
results for the trucks with TRU scenario in calendar year 2000. These results are similar to
carbs results and it gives us confidence in our analysis methodology. The two results on the right
hand side of the graph below the green arrows represent Ramble's results for trucks with TRUs
and the trucks only scenario in calendar year 2023. These show that the cancer risk estimates are below
100 in a million at most distances away from the warehouse fence line. Therefore carbs minimum
siting guidance of 1,000 feet for sensitive receptors located in the vicinity of warehouses is now overly
conservative and should be significantly reduced or eliminated. That concludes my comment. I'm happy
to address any questions from the council members. Thank you. Yeah. Okay, we'll go to the next one
and if we have questions we'll definitely ask. Thank you. So next I will have Mr. Ackerman.
Mayor council members, thank you for the opportunity to speak on this item this evening.
My name is Jason Ackerman. I'm speaking on behalf of Rastavi Transportation Inc.
And Rastavi Freight Transport Inc. Rastavi legally operates in transportation and trucking
brokerage business approximately 6.2 acres located at 9930-9950 Union Street. It is located
in council member Silva's district. The property is zoned MSC. It's immediately adjacent to a very
large MH zoned area. I mentioned that the property is legally operated. It's being
operated pursuant to a conditional use permit that was issued by the county of Riverside.
The conditional use permit has an expiration of July 2024. Rastavi has made substantial
investments in this community through the acquisition of the property spending multiple
millions of dollars acquiring the property in advance of buying the property which it
acquired less than 12 months ago. It spoke with members of planning staff who advised quote,
there was quote, very low to no chance unquote that zoning would change such that the expiration
couldn't be extended or removed altogether. Because of the moratorium, Rastavi has been
unable to process permits to remove the expiration of the conditionally used permit.
At the recommendation of council member Silva, I along with Rosalio and Anna from Rastavi,
Rastavi met with Mr. Perez yesterday and his staff and had a very productive conversation about
the ordinance and its implications. During that conversation, however, we learned that the city
may interpret the grandfathering provisions to preclude Rastavi from operating in additional 40
years because there is an expiration on the conditional use permit. That we believe is
inconsistent with the plain language of section 9.240.008. Today we're asking for
proclamation from this body that if this body adopts the ordinance and at the time that the
ordinance is adopted, that Rastavi will be eligible for a 40 year
continuance of use at this location. Thank you for your time.
Thank you. Next, Mr. Hunter. Hi there. Good evening, Mayor Council staff. My name is Jason Hunter. I
represent the owner of the 1890 Market Street properties located within the Agua Maza study
area. The owner is Rosario Rios. As part of the package before you tonight is a proposal to
initiate a general plan amendment and zoning amendment for the five areas identified by staff to make
them consistent with the city's new trunk intensive use plan. And we support this plan. Absolutely.
A little bit of history with those properties is that obviously they're undeveloped. They were at
one point in time flood zones. Some of those properties are designated as industrial. Some
are designated as waterways in the zoning in the planning code. They are in the Agua Maza
specific plan. But there's been work done over the last decade to get a conditional
letter of map revision from FEMA. And there's been stockpiles granted by stockpiling permits
granted by the city to get that property out of the floodplain. And so it's really ready to go.
And it could be developed. And so we are looking at those properties that are currently W1 and we're
we look at where the city's planning as far as truck intensive use plans. We're looking at what
the Agua Maza specific plan currently is which is mostly industrial and business parks and as you
wear. And we look at the additional benefit that would be to the city of getting those properties
which have been troublesome at times developed and into a productive use. And we would ask that we
as part of that general plan amendment and zoning amendment to get those properties included that
are currently W1, get them into the general plan and into the zoning amendment as industrial
properties consistent with once again the Agua Maza specific plan and the truck intensive use plan.
We'd like to know if the city is already considering these projects as part of the general plan amendment
and zoning amendment because the staff report was a little bit vague for that particular area in
particular what properties were being considered for those changes. And if not we would like to
make that request and would like to know the process we need to undertake to make that a possibility.
I think this could be a really big win for the city of Rupa Valley. Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Hunter. Any other public comments? Anyone? I have no more speaker cards.
As far as goes any e-mailed comments. All right.
With that, I have no further comments. I will close the public hearing.
Bring it back up to council for any discussion comments, questions of staff.
I know I got a few but I'll yield for you guys first.
All right. So, Mr. Perez, I have a question about the how would it affect anything that has a
current potential valid CV with an expiration date?
Well, that is certainly something that we're looking into. So, as Mr. Ackerman indicated earlier,
he raised this issue and we also had our legal council there in the meeting and
in the discussion we advised Mr. Ackerman as well as the property owners who were present
that that is something that we need to look at and not only the there's several issues regarding
this particular conditional use permit. This is a conditional use permit that was approved by the
county and there's some indication that it may or may not be void. So, that's the first thing
we need to determine and Mr. Ackerman indicated that he's sending over information that would
help clarify that issue. And then the second issue regarding the expiration date for the CUP,
whether that is something that prevails over the issue of a 40-year lifespan for legal nonconforming,
that's something that we just have to look at. Again, this was brought to our attention yesterday
and it's something that requires analysis of particularly that section of the code that deals
with legal nonconforming statuses and the amortization of those particular types of uses. So, we don't
have an answer regarding that but we've assured Mr. Ackerman and the property owners that that's
something that we're working with our legal team to determine. So, I would ask and this isn't in no
way focusing on this one site. Should we put some language in there that says if they are a legal
nonconforming use, while we may allow them up to 40 years, would that be on condition of
extending? Because if there are other nonconforming uses with CUPs that are going to expire
before the 40 years, I definitely would not want to give them automatic extensions, if you understand.
So, a language that would indicate that whatever expiration provisions are located or stated within
the existing valid CUPs would be the actual expiration as opposed to allowing them to be extended for
a 40-year period. Is that correct? Yes. That those would prevail. I look to Peter, is that something that?
Mr. Mayor, pro tem and members of the council, I don't think you can do that tonight.
A couple of reasons. First of all, it's not on the agenda. Wasn't something that was considered
by the planning commission. So, we can do it as an amendment if it turns out that that's required.
And I think Mr. Perez made a really good point is that this particular property that Mr. Ackerman
talked about has a lot of complicating issues. And the other thing too is we don't know about
some of the issues on the other properties as to whether or not they fell within the 40-year
amortization period. So, probably the best thing to do is to look closely at the property
that Mr. Ackerman talked about, which we are in the process of doing. And then if there are any
other issues regarding other properties and bring something back if needed that's more comprehensive.
Thank you. So, would it be fair to say that if this gets passed and if it gets passed tonight,
that we could always bring it back for a if in this particular situation if we continue the
moratorium and they have some kind of evidence or some kind of documents that convince staff to
bring this back to council, we could remove them from the moratorium or not as a standalone
item at some point within the next 12 months if they're you know can we can we pull them out of
it as the bottom line. Can we remove the well? I believe we can because in the ordinance and
correct me if I'm wrong here Peter, but in the ordinance itself is that one of the I don't
know that's one of the sites. Yeah, see the the the the moratorium is extended only to sites
that are currently located in the heavy manufacturing zone. This is located outside of that so so
really the moratorium doesn't apply. It's more the other the the other prohibitions of truck
storage that prohibition in the truck intensive use ordinance that would impact this particular
property. I can explain it so under the existing provisions they without this ordinance they
could proceed with a request for a conditional use permit to extend their use. The new truck
intensive use ordinance prohibits the use in this zone so they would no longer be able to
ask for the extension once the ordinance goes into effect which would be 30 days after the second
reading. You say they're no longer allowed to? The use that they have is a basically a truck
distribution use. Okay. And so that use is not allowed in the MSC zone which is the use they're
in under this ordinance. So thank you for the clarification. Let me just go globally here for a
second. The whole point of the bringing this truck moratorium in the first place was because
we have so many trucks in so many places and we wanted to kind of put it all together and figure
out where they're coming from where they're going where where we should have restrictions
and where we shouldn't to help our whole community. And you know I certainly agree with my colleague that
I would never want to give an automatic approval for in essence a non-conforming use of a property
that the whole point of this is to evaluate those types of properties and uses and and clear it up
so in the future we have very clear direction to anybody coming into City Hall that that
wants to have that kind of use they're going to know whether or not they can without you know
blinking and I just opened the book and there it is. We'll talk to a planner and and find out.
But I agree I would the county set things up the way the county did but we as residents of
Roomba Valley banded together to become our own city so that we could make the decisions
and not be living with the ones that were given to us by people who never lived here. So
that may not make a lot of people happy that our business you know we're not trying to
to scurry away people's businesses or hurt them but we as residents who live here have been hurt
for decades so it's time to clean up the mess and this is part of the process unfortunately.
With that I'm okay based on the certification that we can come back and Peter's currently
and staff are currently working with that specific site which then will
I'm assuming lead to if there are further clarification needed we'll come back for an amendment
I'm assuming. All right I'm okay with that. For the ram ball study I appreciate the information
I know we're saying that it's conservative for now I'd rather err on the side of conservative.
Mr. Perez is there any I know this was talked about at the Planning Commission was there any
additional information are there is there a process to let's say do a study for a specific
project to potentially get a variance of that setback. There's always that possibility however
at the Planning Commission level the same information was presented the Planning Commission
had no comments regarding that. I don't know staff I mean our council has any questions about
that study or the setbacks I think airing on the conservative side is given the given that our
community is like mural village and everything that's around trucks that I'd rather err on
you know what we don't know I would like to lift it up to a thousand feet instead of the 500 but I
guess we're okay with 500 right yeah for now okay I'd rather be more conservative and protect our
error and I'd say the good news is things can always come back and they do they come back so
many times you know you blink and somebody's bringing something back with a little tiny
variance and next thing you know we're off and running so just because it said today doesn't mean
that this is the way it's going to be forever and when new information comes to light that will
help make additional decisions and the last comment I have well actually to work on Mr. Blankenship I
respect the the statement about the moratorium I would counter saying I think it's a good idea to
keep these so there's no there's no confusion we just heard someone I you know we can't verify
what we he was told 12 they were told 12 months ago I wouldn't want an applicant or a landowner
developer coming in here and saying oh well I can apply for this not knowing that this is going to
change and then we have people coming here telling us well you told me that I could I would be like
no we're going to change it and we're putting a hold on it and because this is what's going to
happen and we don't want to we don't want you to spend money on something that's just not going to
work no no other comments fair and then for Mr. Hunter I would just say probably follow up with
staff afterwards and figure out those specific sites else on the other I just have a question for
a union street situation is it normal to have an expiration date on on those
condition of approval or this is a rare case well that's it that's in and of itself is a
very interesting subject so I can't speak for all the conditional use permits that were approved
by the county but we are finding as they're coming forward that this wasn't a one-off that there are
other conditional use permits that do have that expiration not all however and do we know why they
would have an expiration date is it like yeah I mean I can only guess right that that perhaps
when the county was processing this they felt that this was an appropriate use but perhaps an
impactful use and that perhaps after a date certain a time that it would expire that the
applicant would have an opportunity to come forward and get either an extension or a new conditional
use permit and a revaluation would occur at that time to see if that use continued to have
or had any negative impacts or if it was operating appropriately so that it didn't have any negative
impacts surrounding uses it's just a way for this the in that case the county to reevaluate
and reassess an existing use that may have negative impacts. Almost like what we're doing now. What's
that? Almost like what we're doing now reevaluating what? Yes in terms of those different study areas
that's absolutely what we're doing yes. I have a question too. You were saying that the property
was just purchased? I believe the property owner of my if memory serves that they purchased around
March I believe we began operating around that time. And the conditional use permit was given
before that to the previous property owner? That's correct. So the county approved that conditional
use permit to for the previous operator and then with that expiration date of 2024 and then the
applicant or this particular property or acquire the property in around that time March of 2021.
And the COP just transfers over to the new owner? Yeah conditional use permits run with the
land. So that's correct. And just to understand a little bit better. The decision we're making
tonight isn't isn't necessarily about their property. We're just it's a much broader application that
the ordinance addresses a lot of properties. So their situation can be brought back later to
understand or when you get the information? We really need it is a complex issue that we're
dealing with here. And so we need more information from the applicant or not the applicant but the
property owner themselves to determine number one the legality of their current operation
and their current conditional use permit. What is the disposition right now of that? And then if
it's determined that they are that it is a legal use under that COP what prevails is it the 2024
expiration or do they fall under the legal nonconforming amortization period of 40 years?
Those are the issues that we're grappling with right now. Thank you. All right.
With that. Mr. Thorson would you please read the title of ordinance number 2021-29?
Yes. Mr. Mayor Pro Teman members of the Council this ordinance number 2021-29 an ordinance of the
city of Herupa Valley amending the Herupa Valley municipal code eliminating expansion or
establishment of truck intensive uses in various commercial industrial and manufacturing zones
adopting additional development standards for certain truck intensive uses and finding an
exemption from CEQA under section 15061 B3 of the CEQA guidelines. And if I could add if as part of
that motion that we could include the sections that Jim had referred to in section 9.240.280
that would clarify vehicle storage and impoundment would be entirely within a closed building with
no outdoor storage allowed and the same would be true for the trailer and boat storage.
That's correct. And with that I will ask for a motion and a second as amended as noted by Mr.
Perez. I just wanted to clarify one scenario to make sure this doesn't impact. It's not going
to impact for example let's say the FedEx facility where they store all their vehicles outside.
This is this is not to do with that's that that that is correct the overlay areas that's a whole
another process. I just wanted to confirm that that's a very good point. Take that away from
the nice and covered the nice of those covered but you know I'd be happier to be honest if I know
if Costco got all those trucks off the street and built the parking lot that when we right
that they're going to when we brought the moratorium up a year ago they said they were in plans to
to do that and that was part of the discussion we had during that hearing about the more
it may be staff can follow up with them and bring this back some information if that's happening
because they're still lined up there every day or every night. Anyway so we got a motion by
Altamorano and a second by Silva so all in favor aye and you against all right passes 4-0
Mr. Thorson would you please read the title of ordinance number 2021 dash yeah would you like
to take action on agenda items two and three the initiating the general plan amendment and
initiating the zoning amendment yes that's just a simple motion by the council thank you I get
a motion and a second for that thank you second thank you all in favor for an items number two and
three aye any against all right thank you pass 4-0 Mr. Thorson would you please read the title
of ordinance number 2021 dash 30 yes madam or mr. Mayor Pro Teman members of the city council
ordinance number 21 2021 dash 30 is an interim urgency ordinance of the city council of the city
of arupa valley california extending interim urgency ordinance number 2021 dash 0 5 limiting the scope
of and imposing a temporary moratorium pursuant to government code section 65858 on the expansion
or establishment of truck intensive uses on real properties identified as assessor parcel numbers
1 7 4 dash 0 4 0 dash 0 1 7 dash 0 1 8 dash 0 1 9 and dash 0 2 0 1 7 5 dash 0 8 0 dash 0 0 7
1 7 8 dash 3 3 0 dash 0 0 1 dash 0 0 2 and dash 0 0 3 1 6 3 dash 400 dash 0 0 4 dash 0 0 0 8
and dash 0 4 6 and 1 8 1 dash 1 1 9 dash 0 1 and dash and dash 0 1 0 within the manufacturing heavy
mh zone and making a determination of exemption under siqua guideline section 15061 b3
thank you peter requires a four fifth spoke so with that can i get a motion and a second
thank you second all in favor aye any against all right passes for thank you thank you everyone
with that we'll move on to number 14 council business 14a introduction of an ordinance
amending section 2.05.100 of the harup of